last night friends and family members  held a vigil for a father  grandfather and a husband killed in a  suspected dui crash  52-year-old eric echevarria died last  wednesday  his vehicle was hit near blue diamond  and ford apache by a suspected drunk  driver  echevarria was an army vet and worked as  a ccsd custodian for  18 years he took a dad from my 14 year  old son he took my husband my  my best friend my life partner my my  everything i don't even know what i'm  going to do without him  prosecutors have charged 19-year-old  unlv basketball recruit zan collins with  several charges for causing that crash  he is due back in court this thursday